ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVIN NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. I AGREE ARE
CURRY. ARAMBULA BARRICADE HAND.
BENNETT BERMAN. BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA. BURKE
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAO
CHEN. CHIU CHOI. COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY. DAVIES
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL. GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GONZALEZ GRAY. GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER. KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEAD.
LEVINE LOW. MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA. MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THE SYRIAN WHEN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO THEY ARE TO SMITH
STONE TEAM VALIDATORS VIA
PALUDOSA VOEPEL WALDRON WARD
WEBER. WICKS WOOD THE SPEAKER.
EVERY STORY WE'RE NORMALLY OF.
REMEMBER. I DON'T KNOW ALL
RIGHT RIGHT. YEAH.
DAVID. THANK
YOU.
I'M NONE OF THEIR PLEASE.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN. IMAM
YASIR KHAN IMAM YES HERE. IN
THE NAME OF GOD. THE MOST
GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL. I'M
NOT A GUN. MAKERS ALWAYS
CONSCIOUS OF OUR PURPOSE AND
USEFULNESS IN THIS WORLD. HELP
US TO SEE AND USE NEW
OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE ALL OF US
MORE TRULY HUMAN IN THIS PERIOD
OF HISTORY. DURING THESE
DIFFICULT TIMES GIVE US THE
ABILITY AND THE WILL TO ACT
WITH THE RIGHTFUL PURPOSE. LET
US REMEMBER THAT IT IS OUR DUTY
TO SERVE NOT ONLY OUR FELLOW
CALIFORNIANS. BUT TO ALSO SERVE
GOD IN A MANNER. THAT DOES US
HONOR INDIVIDUALLY AND AS A
BODY I MEAN. WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WARD AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER MARK THANK YOU
PLACE YOUR RIGHT HAND OVER YOUR
HEART READY BEGIN. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. TO
AND ASIAN. IT IS. FOR ALL.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL GOLDEN ONE CENTER
SACRAMENTO MONDAY DECEMBER
SEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY PURSUANT
TO THE PROVISIONS OF THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AT THE HOUR OF
TWELVE O'CLOCK TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO REGULAR SESSION
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
WAS CALLED TO ORDER BY C.
PARKER CHIEF FOR THE ASSEMBLY
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
REGULAR SESSION. CONFORMITY
WITH THE LAW THE FOLLOWING
OFFICES WERE ALSO PRESENT A. B.
LEACH MINUTE CLERK AND LISA
BUCKLEY CHIEF SERGEANT AT ARMS
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY DAYS
RAMOS MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS BUT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
OF PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY. FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS GRAYSON. MURATSUCHI AND
CHEN. FOR MEDICAL LEAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FRAZIER. ANCOR.
HEY MISTER RAMOS. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FOR FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS CARILLO
FONG COME LONGER CREEK SILVA
AND- YEP- THE ONE TO SPEAK ON
AN ADJOURNMENTS. IN MEMORY
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I MOVE TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX TO WITHDRAW SENATE BILL
EIGHTY NINE AND NINETY ONE
SKINNER. FROM THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND PLACE THEM ON THE
SECOND READING FILE. MR FLORIO
RECOMMENDS YOU MISTER SPEAKER
WE WITHHOLD IN ASKING SANTA
CLAUS FOR ROLL CALL VOTE.
MISTER FLOOR IS WITHHOLDING MS
RAMOS MOVES. AND MISTER WARD%
SECONDS ON THE ROLE SUSPENSION
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE. CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ISRAEL THIS IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE. MISTER FLORES ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE. MS RADIUS IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. M.
MISTER FLORA NOW. THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE. THIS IS
PROCEDURAL. THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL EYES FORTY FOUR
KNOWS THIRTEEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED MISS RAMOS YOUR AGAIN
RECOGNIZED MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE FOR SIXTY
TWO A THE FOLLOWING NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO MEET THIS
WEDNESDAY JANUARY TWENTY
SEVENTH AT NINE AM FOR AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
EVICTION MORATORIUM EXTENSION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. MEMBERS AND I COULD
HAVE YOUR ATTENTION. WE WOULD
ASK THAT YOU PLEASE CONTINUE TO
OBSERVE. PHYSICAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ON THE FLOOR THE
ASSEMBLY PLEASE BE MINDFUL OF
YOUR SOCIAL DISTANCING IN ALL
OF YOUR CONVERSATIONS ON THE
FLOOR THE ASSEMBLY.  MEMBERS A
QUICK ANNOUNCEMENT TODAY IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALLED THE
WRONGS BIRTHDAY LET'S WISH HER
A HAPPY. AND WHEN YOU SEE
MISTER OFSHE KALRA HE RECENTLY
CELEBRATED A BIRTHDAY AS WELL
HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO MISTER KALRA.
NOW WE ARE MOVING TO BUSINESS
ON THE DAILY FILE. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE HR TEN. KAKORI
HOUSE RESOLUTION TEN BY SUMMER
CALDERONE RELATIVE TO WOMEN'S
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH. MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
MISTER CALDERON. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PREVENT
HR TEN COMMEMORATING THE FORTY
EIGHTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
DECISION IN ROE V. WADE
AFFIRMING EVERY WOMAN HAS A
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO CONTROL
HER OWN REPRODUCTIVE DECISIONS.
AND WHETHER TO CONTINUE A
PREGNANCY OR OBTAIN AN ABORTION.
ROVI WITH A VICTORY FOR WOMEN
TO TELL THEIR OWN BODIES. AND
LAID THE GROUNDWORK FOR FURTHER
REPRODUCTIVE AND SEXUAL HEALTH
CARE POLICIES THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY. IT IS VITAL FOR
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS HOME TO
NEARLY TWENTY MILLION WOMEN. TO
RECOGNIZE AND CELEBRATE THESE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS. ESPECIALLY
DURING A TIME WHEN PROVIDERS OF
REPRODUCTIVE AND SEXUAL HEALTH
CARE LIKE PLANNED PARENTHOOD
ARE UNDER SERIOUS UNRELENTING
ATTACKS. FOR PROVIDING SAFE AND
LEGAL REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE.
DESPITE THE SUPPORT AND THE NEW
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION THE
RIGHT TO LEGAL ABORTION IS
INCREASINGLY BECOMING A RIDE IN
NAME ALONE. SIX STATES HAVE
ONLY ONE REMAINING ABORTION
CLINIC AND 90% OF US COUNTIES
INCLUDING 40% OF CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES DO NOT HAVE AN
ABORTION PROVIDER. WITH THE
CHANGE IN THE COMPOSITION OF
THE SUPREME COURT INCLUDING AMY
CONEY BARRETT'S CONFRONT
CONFIRMATION TO THE COURT AND
TWENTY TWENTY. ABORTION ACCESS
IS AT EXTREME RISK. RIGHT NOW
THERE ARE NINETEEN CASES
ADDRESSING ABORTION RIGHTS ONLY
ONE STEP AWAY FROM THE SUPREME
COURT. MANY RODE THE WAVE COULD
BE OVERTURNED- FURTHER THAT IT.
ELIMINATING WHAT LITTLE ACCESS
IS LEFT ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES. HR TEN SOLIDIFIES THE
ASSEMBLY SUPPORT AND COMMITMENT
TO PROTECT A WOMAN'S
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO DECIDE. IF
AND WHEN THEY BECOME A PARENT.
AS WE MARK ROBEY WEIGHTS FORTY
EIGHT ANNIVERSARY. NOW MORE
THAN EVER. WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THE EXISTENCE OF THE LEGAL
RIGHT TO ABORTION ISN'T ENOUGH.
WE NEED TO EXPAND ACCESS OF
THAT REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM IS A
REALITY FOR EVERY PERSON. WE
MUST URGE THE BIDEN
MINISTRATION TO FIGHT BACK AND
UNDO THE HARPER TRUMPCARE
POLICIES. AND CONTINUE TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO ABORTION AND
SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTHCARE IN CALIFORNIA. I
LIKE MANY VIEW STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF A WOMAN'S
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS AS CONFIRMED
IN ROE V. WADE. TO MAKE THEIR
OWN DECISIONS REGARDING THEIR
PREGNANCY AND- JR AYE VOTE ON
HR. TEN THANK YOU MISTER
CALDERON. SEEING NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. MS
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
HEY GOOD MORNING MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF HR TEN WHICH
RECOGNIZES THE FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT OF EVERY WOMAN TO CONTROL
THEIR OWN REFERENCE
REPRODUCTIVE DECISIONS
INCLUDING THE INTIMATE CHOICE
TO CONTINUE YOUR PREGNANCY OR
OBTAIN ABORTION. OF CALIFORNIA
LEADERS EVEN VOTE FOR THIS
DEVASTATING EPIDEMIC WE HAVE
SEEN FIRST HAND THE IMPORTANCE
OF LIFESAVING ACCESS TO
PERSONALIZED WHOLE PERSON
HEALTH CARE. JUST YESTERDAY OR
THE DAY BEFORE PRESIDENT BIDEN
TOOK AN OATH TO SERVE BY
UNITING OUR NATION AND
UPLIFTING ALL AMERICANS FROM
THE UNIMAGINABLE LOSS.
DEVASTATION AND DIVISION FELL
OVER THE PAST FOUR YEARS AND
ACUTELY OVER THE COURSE OF THE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. IT IS OUR DUTY TO
PROTECT AND EXPAND NOT TAKE
AWAY ACCESS TO ALL FORMS OF
HEALTH CARE. IT IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURE THE BASIC RIGHT TO
REPRODUCTIVE AND SEXUAL HEALTH
CARE IS AVAILABLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS. I URGE YOU
MEMBERS TO SUPPORT HR TEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY. SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION.
MISTER CALDERON YOU MAY CLOSE
IF YOU WISH. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL
COMMENTS I REQUEST THE FIRST
WILL CALL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON HR TEN. MEMBERS THIS
ROLL CALL WILL BE FOR CO
AUTHORS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE HOUSE RESOLUTION CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS MEMBERS. CO AUTHORS
ONE HR. TEN THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. THE CLERK WELL CLOSER
ROLE THERE ARE FIFTY CO AUTHORS
ADDED WE WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT H. R. TEN
IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS IN THE
ABSENCE OF OBJECTION WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. MEMBERS I'M GOING TO
ASK THAT YOU PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS. OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR
OF THE ASSEMBLY. PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS AND GIVE YOUR
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION YOUR
COLLEAGUES. WILL BE TURNING THE
MEMORY.
MEMBERS WE ARE
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS
WE ARE DETERMINES THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS A RANDOM PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
IN MEMORY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY
I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE AND HONOR
TO REMEMBER TOMMY LASORDA WHO
WAS A FULLERTON RESIDENT.
THOMAS CHARLES LASORDA WAS BORN
SEPTEMBER TWENTY SECOND
NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN IN
NORRISTOWN PENNSYLVANIA. HIGHLY
REGARDED AS BASED POLLS MOST
POPULAR AMBASSADOR LASORDA
SPENT SEVENTY ONE SEASONS IN
THE DODGER ORGANIZATION
BLEEDING DODGER BLUE. NOW HE
FINALLY JOINS THE BIG DODGER
FAMILY IN THE SKY. WITH A
CAREER THAT SPANS GENERATIONS
TIMELY LASORDA CAPTURED THE
HEARTS OF BASEBALL FANS AND ALL
OF THOSE WHO HAD THE PRIVILEGE
OF MEETING HIM. AS A JUNIOR
HIGH STUDENT IN FULLER TEN. HE
CAME TO VISIT MY JUNIOR HIGH
AND HE WAS ALSO A GOOD FRIEND
OF A TEACHER THERE. AND HE WAS
SO GENEROUS THAT HE GAVE
TICKETS TO DODGER BASEBALL
GAMES NOT ONLY DID HE GIVE
TICKETS BUT THIS TEACHER IN
FACT TOOK MYSELF. ANOTHER
CLASSMATE TO MY VERY FIRST
DODGER GAVE. THOSE WERE THE
STEVE GARVEY DAYS. AND I
REMEMBER ALSO HAVING MY FIRST
DODGER. HOT DOG WHO CAN FORGET
THAT HIS STORIES AND
EXPERIENCES INSPIRED NOT ONLY
MYSELF BUT MANY TO BECOME
LIFELONG DODGER FANS. AS A
DODGER FAN MYSELF I'M GRATEFUL
TO HAVE HAD THIS INCREDIBLE MAN
LIVING IN MY ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
MY HOMETOWN OF FULLER TEN. A
HUMBLE MAN MR LASORDA WOULD
OFTEN SHOW UP AT LOCAL
RESTAURANTS AND BALL GAMES AND
HE WAS GRACIOUS WITH HIS TIME.
TAMI ALMOST ALWAYS SAID HIS
PLAYERS IF SOMEONE ASKS FOR AN
AUTOGRAPH SIGN IT. A TRUE HIM
AT YOU BUT THE HUMANITARIAN AND
A POPULAR SPEAKER. MISTER
LASORDA ADDRESSED TROOPS AT
MORE THAN FORTY MILITARY BASES
ACROSS THE WORLD. INCLUDING A
FIVE COUNTRY GOODWILL TOUR IN
TWO THOUSAND NINE. AND TWENTY
FOURTEEN HE WAS RECOGNIZED WITH
THE BOB FELLER ACT OF VALOR
AWARD. FOR DISPLAYING THE SAME
VALUES INTEGRITY AND DEDICATION
TO SERVING THE UNITED STATES AS
FELLER A HALL OF FAME PITCHER
WHO SERVED IN WORLD WAR TWO.
WELL SORT OF PLAYED A HUGE ROLE
IN THE GLOBALIZATION OF THE
GAME OF BASEBALL. FORMER
COMMISSIONER ALLEN H. BUD SELIG
APPOINTED HIM AS THE OFFICIAL
AMBASSADOR OF THE NEW YORK
RURAL WORLD BASEBALL CLASSIC IN
TWO THOUSAND SIX. AND AGAIN IN
TWO THOUSAND NINE CLASSIC THAT
WAS PLAYED AT DODGER STADIUM.
AND THAT CAPACITY LASORDA
SERVED AS A SPOKESPERSON FOR
THE TOURNAMENT AND THE TEAM'S
GOLD MEDAL WHICH LASORDA
CONSIDERS HIS GREATEST
PROFESSIONAL ACHIEVEMENT MARKED
HIS RETURN TO THE DUGOUT AFTER
HIS RETIREMENT IN NINETEEN
NINETY SIX. LESQUELLES LES
SORTED HAS BEEN QUOTED IN
SAYING THAT. DODGER STADIUM WAS
HIS ADDRESS BUT EVERY BAR
BALLPARK WITH HIS HOME. TODAY
WE AT THE STATE CAPITOL AS
ANOTHER HOME FOR THE LATE GREAT
TOMMY LASORDA. AND FOR MY
COLLEAGUES AND FRIENDS TAMI
ALSO USED TO SAY IF YOU DON'T
LOVE THE DODGERS. THERE'S A
GOOD CHANCE YOU MAY NOT GET
INTO HEAVEN. AND WITH THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR INJURED IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISS CLARK SILVA MS
CARILLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO HONOR
THE MEMORY OF THOMAS OF FLORIDA
LEGENDARY AMBASSADOR OF THE LOS
ANGELES DODGERS AND THE ENTIRE
GAME OF BASEBALL WELL HIS HOME
MAY HAVE BEEN IN FULLERTON HIS
HEART WAS NESTLED IN THE HILLS
OF ELYSIAN VALLEY. AND IT BLED
DODGER BLUE RIGHT AT DODGER
STADIUM IN THE FIFTY FIRST
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT WHICH I AM SO
HONORED TO REPRESENT. TELL ME
WITH A WARM AND BOISTEROUS
PRESENT THE TRULY PERSONIFIED
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES HE
SPENT SEVENTY YEARS WITH THE
DODGERS ORGANIZATION INCLUDING
TWENTY AS MANAGER WAS INDUCTED
INTO THE BASEBALL HALL OF FAME
IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN AND
HAD HIS PORTRAIT ADDED TO THE
SMITHSONIAN NATIONAL PORTRAIT
GALLERY IN TWO THOUSAND NINE.
TAMI BROUGHT PEOPLE TOGETHER
AROUND THE GAME OF BASEBALL
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD. HE
LEARNED SPANISH VISITED CLOSE
TO THIRTY COUNTRIES AND
CONSIDERED WINNING THE OLYMPIC
GOLD MEDAL. IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN USA AS ONE OF HIS
CROWNING. ACHIEVEMENT AND TAMI
ALSO GAVE BACK HE VISITED OUR
MEN AND WOMEN IN UNIFORM
OVERSEAS AND SERVED AS A
SPOKESMAN FOR THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION. AND THE
PROSTATE CANCER FOUNDATION.
TOMMY LASORDA WILL ALWAYS BE
REMEMBERED AS A GREAT ANGELINO.
AND A GREAT CALIFORNIANS. HE
TRAVELED TO TEXAS LAST FALL TO
SEE THE DODGERS WIN GAME SIX OF
THE WORLD SERIES AND HIS
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE GAME OF
BASEBALL. WILL UNDOUBTEDLY BE
VISIBLE FOR GENERATIONS TO COME.
HE IS KNOWN TO HAVE GIVEN A LOT
OF ADVICE IN HIS TIME WITH THE
DODGERS. I MET HIM ON A FEW
OCCASIONS AND HE TOLD ME HIS
STORY OF. COMING UP OF FOR THE
BLUE COLLAR FAMILY OF. ITALIAN
IMMIGRANT PARENTS AND HE TOLD
ME THAT I SHOULD FIND MYSELF A
GOOD ITALIAN BOY IN MY LIFE AND
I'VE YET TO COMPLETE THAT TASK
BUT- HOPEFULLY SOON. I REMEMBER
JUMPING FOR JOY IN NINETEEN
NINETY NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT AS
A LITTLE GIRL IN MY PARENTS
LIVING ROOM. WHEN THE DODGERS
WON THE WORLD SERIES AS KIRK
GIBSON MADE HISTORY AND RAN
AROUND THOSE BASES. AND JUST
LAST YEAR JUMPING AGAIN AND MY
PARENTS SAME LIVING ROOM.
THINKING ABOUT HOW LONG IT HAD
BEEN AS THE DODGERS AGAIN WON
THE WORLD SERIES. THIS TIME
AMID A GLOBAL PANDEMIC. AND I
REMEMBER THINKING MAN. BASEBALL
IS AN INCREDIBLE GAME AND FEW
PEOPLE CAN MATCH THE LEVEL OF
IT AS THE GREAT TOMMY LASORDA
TOMMY IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
OF SEVENTY YEARS JOE. WHO HE
MARRIED IN NINETEEN FIFTY THEIR
DAUGHTER LAURA AND THEIR
GRANDDAUGHTER EMILY TESTS.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES AND ON
BEHALF OF THE UNOFFICIAL
DODGERS CAUCUS IN THIS CHAMBER
THE MANY FANS AND THE FRENEMIES
FROM THE BAY AREA WHO
APPRECIATE THE GREATEST RIVALRY
IN BASEBALL OF ALL TIME THE
DODGERS VERSUS GIANTS. I WOULD
LIKE TO RETURN IN THE MEMORY OF
TOMMY LASORDA TODAY AND FOR THE
LOVE OF THE GAME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO. A
MYSTERY ARE YOU WERE AGAIN
RECOGNIZED FOR AN ADDITIONAL
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO HONOR THE
MEMORY OF KATHLEEN IT SHOULD
CONEY STEVENS A LONGTIME
VOLUNTEER PUBLIC SERVANT
COMMUNITY LEADERS AND RESIDENTS
OF NORTHEAST LOS ANGELES AND
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY ONE.
KATHLEEN WAS DEDICATED TO
HELPING HER COMMUNITY AND
NEIGHBORHOOD IN ANYWAY POSSIBLE
AND WAS EVIDENT WITH THE MANY
POSITION SHE HELD THROUGHOUT
HER LIFE. SHE SERVED AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE PARENT TEACHER
ASSOCIATION OF EAGLE ROCK
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL THE
NEIGHBORHOOD WATCH CAPTAIN L.
A. U. AS THE CLASS MOM AND A
SOFTBALL COACH AT THE ALLEY
CITY PUBLIC PARK. IN EVERY
PLACE SHE THIRD SHE WAS LIKE A
MOM TO EVERYONE SHE MET
KATHLEEN WAS ALSO INVOLVED IN A
VARIETY OF COMMUNITY PROJECT
THE NEIGHBORHOOD EFFORTS SUCH
AS OPERATION SPARKLE AT EAGLE
ROCK ELEMENTARY PROJECTS TO
BEAUTIFY THE NEIGHBORHOOD AN UP
LIFT YOUNG PEOPLE. SHE WAS THE
FIRST IN HER FAMILY TO OBTAIN A
DEGREE IN GRADUATE FROM CAL
STATE LOS ANGELES AND IN HER
LIFETIME KATHLEEN TAUGHT US
WHAT PUBLIC SERVICE IS TRULY
ABOUT. SELFLESSNESS DEDICATION
HUMILITY AND CONSIDERATION FOR
OTHERS SHE WAS A TRUE COMMUNITY
STEWART KATHLEEN IS SURVIVED BY
BRUCE HER HUSBAND OF FORTY
THREEYEARS HER SON AND MY
FRIEND JAKE UP THEIR DAUGHTER
AMBER. AND HER GRANDDAUGHTER
HELLO AT THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
AND I ASK THAT WE ARE TURNING
KATHLEEN STEPHENS MEMORY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS KOREA.
MISTER V. APPROVED BY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS IT IS WITH DEEP
SADNESS AND GREAT RESPECT THAT
ARRIVED TODAY TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF MY DEAR FRIEND RAY
MORALES. WHO RECENTLY PASSED
AWAY IT WAS A PILLAR OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND A MENTOR TO MANY
PEOPLE. HE SERVED IN OUR
MILITARY DURING THE VIETNAM
CONFLICT AS A MARINE AND SHOWED
HIS PATRIOTISM EVERY DAY OF HIS
LIFE. HE WITH THE POLITICAL
LEADER SERVING ON. THE FIRST
MEXICAN AMERICAN TRACY CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER. RAY GAVE TRACY
SO MUCH BY SUPPORTING AND
SERVING COUNTLESS COMMITTEES
AND BOARDS INCLUDING THE TRACY
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. THE TRACY
CENTREBOARD THE TRACY HISPANIC
BOARD BUSINESS GROUP. SOUTH
SIDE COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION
TRACY IS BANNING BUSINESS GROUP
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM LATINO BUT
LEADERSHIP AWARD AND MANY
OTHERS. RAY WAS A MENTOR AND A
PERFECT EXAMPLE OF WHAT LEADERS
SHOULD BE. I WAS HONORED TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY MEXICAN AMERICAN HALL OF
FAME WITH MR MORALIS. AND
WALTER AGUSTINA. WHAT A NIGHT
RAY WAS A MAN OF DIGNITY
RESOLVE AN IMPECCABLE INTEGRITY
I PRAY FOR HIS FAMILY MAY THE
LORD HELP THIS FAMILY DURING
THESE DIFFICULT TIMES THEY CAN
SPEAK. THANK YOU SIR MR HONG
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
TERM MEMORY. BUT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS A TODAY
I RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF A. WAY ON JANUARY THIRD JOHN
FIRST MOVED TO BAKERSFIELD IN
NINETEEN SIXTY LATER ATTENDING
BIXEL COLLEGE AND THEN UCLA.
SOON AFTER HE MOVED BACK TO
WORK FOR THE BIG CITY SCHOOL
DISTRICT BEGINNING IS IMPACTFUL
CAREER EDUCATION. JOHN SERVED
AS THE PRINCIPAL APPROVED-
JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL FOR THIRTY
YEARS BRINGING THE SCHOOL
RECOGNITION AS A CALIFORNIA
DISTINGUISHED SCHOOL AND AS A
NATIONAL BLUE RIBBON SCHOOL OF
EXCELLENCE. HIS ENERGY
SURPASSED ALL THOSE AROUND HIM
HE KNEW EVERY STUDENT BY NAME
AND HE KNEW THOSE THAT NEEDED
AN EXTRA AMOUNT OF COMPASSION.
HE ALSO WAS INSTRUMENTAL AS A
HISTORY DAY COACH LEADING
STUDENTS TO VICTORY AT THE
STATE LEVEL AND BECOMING KNOWN
AS A POWER HOUSE AT NATIONAL
HISTORY DAY COMPETITION. NOW
OUTSIDE THE CLASSROOM JOHN
SPURRED THE GROWTH OF THE
BIGGEST OLD SISTER CITY
PROGRAM. JOHN SIR DID SERVE
DILIGENTLY AS A WORLD
AMBASSADOR TO BIGGEST FOR
BAKERSFIELD VISITING SISTER
CITIES ACROSS THE GLOBE IN
JAPAN CHINA BELARUS MEXICO
SOUTH KOREA INDIA AND FRANCE
WITH HIS STUDENTS. YOU WILL
SINCERELY MISS SUCH A TRUE
FRIEND OF OUR COMMUNITY HIS
LESSONS IN LEADERSHIP
COMPASSION AND OF COURSE
ACADEMICS HAVE ENDEARED HIM
FOREVER THOUSAND AND I ASK THAT
THE ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED. IN HIS
MEMORY TODAY. THANK YOU MISTER.
AND MISS KAMLAGER. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. FOR YOUR TERMINATE THE
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF BERNARD BERNIE
ROLLINS WHO PSSED AWAY ON
MONDAY DECEMBER TWENTY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY HE WAS EIGHTY
SEVEN YEARS OLD. BERNIE WAS A
RESIDENT OF THE FIFTY FOURTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT HE WAS BORN
IN NINETEEN THIRTY THREE IN BED
STUY BROOKLYN AND RAISED BY HIS
BARBADIAN MOTHER JESSICA DARK.
BERNIE GREW THROUGHOUT
CHILDHOOD SURROUNDED BY AN
ARRAY OF MULTICULTURAL FAMILY
AND FRIENDS WHOM HE WAS KNOWN
TO SKETCH. IN NINETEEN FIFTY
NINE HE SETTLED IN LA UTILIZING
HIS DEGREE IN CIVIL ENGINEERING
TO WORK IN THE BURGEONING
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY. CREATING
ART REMAIN THE DISTINCT HOBBY A
HOBBY HE GREW SO PASSIONATE FOR
IT ACTUALLY BEGAN TO COMPETE
WITH HIS DAY JOB WITH WORD
SPREADING ABOUT HIS CREATIVE
SKILLS. THE MULTI TALENTED
ENTREPRENEUR JOHN DANIELS HIRED
ROLLINS TO HELP CONCEPTUALIZE
THE STYLE AND LOOK FOR HIS
MUSIC VENUE IN THE LOS ANGELES
CRENSHAW DISTRICT TO BE CALLED
MAVERICKS BLACK. THE CLUB
QUICKLY BECAME AS THE APOLLO OF
THE WEST CONSEQUENTLY BROWN'S
IS WORKING GREATER RECOGNITION
THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN CAL. IN
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX HE ACCEPTED
A JOB DESIGNING AIRFIELDS AND
BRIDGES IN AND AROUND SAIGON
VIETNAM. AROUND THE SAME TIME
HE WAS APPROACHED BY THE
PUBLISHERS OF LA BASED SOLE
NEWSPAPER TO BE THE ART
DIRECTOR OF THEIR MONTHLY
LITERARY MAGAZINE SOUL
ILLUSTRATED. THE GRAPHIC
DESIGNS FOR THE FIRST TWO
ADDITIONS HAD TO BE MAILED BACK
AND FORTH FROM VIETNAM DURING
WARTIME. BERNIE RETURNED TO LA
IN NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT WHERE
HE DEVOTED HIMSELF ENTIRELY TO
HIS ART. IN THE EARLY SEVENTIES
HE CO WROTE THE INFLUENTIAL TV
SERIES OF BLACK ON THE BUS
STARRING JAMES EARL JONES.
DURING THE LATE SEVENTIES AND
INTO THE EIGHTIES BERNIE WORKED
IN FILM BEGINNING WITH THIS
COLLABORATION WITH JON DANIELS
I'M GETTING OVER AND CONTINUING
WITH THIS FILM PRODUCTION
COMPANY CHOCOLATE CHIP
PRODUCTION. IN NINETEEN NINETY
ONE BERNIE MAC FRENCH AMAT. THE
NEWLY RELOCATED DIRECTOR OF
UCLA'S CALIFORNIA SELF HELP
CENTER. AFTER HE POSTED AN AD
FOR A ROMANTIC PARTNER IN LA
WEEKLY. BOTH WERE ORIGINALLY
FROM BROOKLYN BY WAY OF
BARBADOS THEY MARRIED IN
NINETEEN NINETY THREE. DEVOTED
TO EACH OTHER PERSONALLY AND
PROFESSIONALLY OVER THE PAST
SEVENTEEN YEARS BERNIE AND FRAN
RAN JAMAAT ROLLINS GROUP. TO
GATHER THEY CONSULTED WITH
MAJOR PHILANTHROPIC FOUNDATIONS
RANGING FROM CONRAD HILTON TO
BLUE SHIELD OF CALIFORNIA TO
LIBERTY HILL. A SOCIAL ACTIVIST
THEY WERE INFLUENTIAL OFTEN
SHEPHERDING YOUNG PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT CIVIC
AND POLITICAL ENGAGEMENT IS. UP
UNTIL HIS PASSING ROLLINS
CONTINUED HIS ART MOST RECENTLY
WITH TRYING TO COMPLETED FOR A
SOON TO BE PUBLISHED CHILDREN'S
BOOK ON THE LIFE OF JAZZ
MUSICIAN CLARK TERRY. BERNIE
LEAVES BEHIND HIS LOVING WIFE
FRANCES THEIR BLENDED FAMILY
WHICH INCLUDES THEIR CHILDREN
GRANDCHILDREN AND HIS TWO
BROTHERS. BERNIE ROLLINS WAS A
CREATIVE POWERHOUSE AND A
THOUGHTFUL MENTOR AND HE WILL
BE MISSED BY HIS FAMILY HIS
FRIENDS AND HIS COMMUNITY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A JOURNEYING
IN THE MEMORY OF BERNIE ROLLINS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
KAMLAGER THANK YOU MEMBERS
MEMBERS MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
PLEASE NOTE THE SESSIONS%
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
JANUARYTWENTY SIXTH CHECK IN
SESSION. WEDNESDAY JANUARY
TWENTY SEVENTH FOR STATION FOR
SESSION IS AT NOON THAT'S
WEDNESDAY JANUARY TWENTY
SEVENTH FLOOR SESSION AT TWELVE
PM THURSDAY. JANUARY TWENTY
EIGHTH FOUR SESSIONS AT NINE AM
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED. SEEING
HEARING OR FOR THE BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN. MS REYES MOVES MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
WEDNESDAY JANUARY TWENTY
SEVENTH AT TWELVE PM IN THE
FORM CALL IS LIFTED.